hello there YouTube I'm John Oliver
last week tonight is still not quite
back on the air and yet I'm still
popping up here occasionally to ruin
everybody's holidays why why because by
now everyone is probably sick of them
Kanaka has come and gone christmas just
passed and as everyone knows right now
we're just wrapping up Kwanzaa and if
you celebrate any of those holidays
you're undoubtedly exhausted if you
celebrate all of them your last name
probably has several hyphens in it but
tonight brings a holiday that unites all
of us no matter our religious background
or ethnicity and it unites us in hating
it and that's New Year's Eve New Year's
Eve is like the death of a pet you know
it's going to happen but somehow you're
never really prepared for how truly
awful it is New Year's Eve is the worst
it combines three of the least Pleasant
things known to mankind
forced interaction with strangers being
drunk cold and tired and having to stare
at Ryan Seacrest for five solid minutes
waiting thing to tell you what the time
is honestly the best thing you can do is
avoid the whole evening and to do that
you're going to need some excellent and
specific excuses and this is where we
come in so first here's a scenario let's
say you have a friend who just got
divorced and wants to hang out and do
some guy stuff this is a tricky one
because guy stuff as we all know is code
for strip clubs and you should
absolutely not spend New Year's Eve in a
strip club
unless Ebola goes airborne and the only
cure is glitter that's the only that's
the only appropriate moment to do that
so what you need to do tell your friend
that your cousin Paul smecker has
suddenly become ill and that he needs
some of your bones imes now clearly none
of that's true
bones I'm czar a thing I just made up
and Paul smecker is the name of Willem
Dafoe's character in The Boondock Saints
and is until oh if your friend knows
that offhand cut him out of your life
forever
that's a terrible movie either way
you're free okay so um second scenario
let's say you've been invited to a party
at a friend's house
obviously you don't want to go that's a
five-hour commitment if you leave at
12:01 think of it this way do you really
want to sit on your friends sulfur and
watch hummus turn brown all night no
nobody does so here's the trick and this
actually works for everything Oh New
Year's Eve parties it works for bar
mitzvahs wakes it works for everything
simply tell them you're doing a cleanse
now true here's a thing yes you're right
that's not technically an excuse but the
beauty is there will be no follow-up
questions because nobody wants to hear
about your cleanse nobody so
your apps you're out lastly lastly if
you're invited out on a girls night I
can't really help you and I'll tell you
why I've never been asked to join a
girls night which i think is because I'm
such a Samantha and women are
intimidated by my energy that's what I'm
guessing but what I'm saying what I'm
saying is the best way to celebrate the
spirit of New Year's Lea Eve is by lying
the first line of auld lang syne should
be should auld acquaintance be forgot
and there's no better way of doing that
than completely blowing off all your
friends and family and if you do this
right you will be in bed on New Year's
Eve at 11:45 after watching all five die
hard movies happy New Year to all of you
we will be back in 2015